el redoblar de los tambores hace temblar
las paredes en la serie de la escuela de
samba vila isabel
hacía casi 2 años que estos
percusionistas no sentían el calor de
los ensayos que preceden el carnaval
los números de la pandemia están bajando
conseguimos avanzar con la vacunación
para ensayar en el local social de esta
escuela todos tienen que presentar el
certificado de vacunación
esperamos que la ciudad mejore nos
estamos preparando para llegar en este
febrero de conseguir hacer un carnaval
muy bonito para que todo el mundo con
memoria
una explosión de júbilo se apodera de
los cuerpos de estos bailarines que por
fin pueden mostrar de nuevo sus
habilidades
[Música]
es como si hubiese vuelto la alegría y
nuestros ojos volviesen a brillar estoy
muy agradecida porque hemos sobrevivido
a algo muy malo entonces será la fiesta
de la vida equilibra
todo cuidado es poco para proteger a los
más veteranos de esta escuela de samba
en otra punta de la ciudad los músicos
del grupo benjamín y a flor afinan sus
instrumentos
es un recomienzo prácticamente de todo
es nuestro segundo ensayo generalmente
volvemos a ensayar en septiembre o sea
estamos dos meses atrasados todo el
mundo está volviendo a verse ahora creo
que será un carnaval de mucha locura la
demanda reprimida es fuerte
en las calles de río de janeiro
desfilarán más de 500 comparsas como
esta
[Música]
desde 2016 este grupo inunda el centro
de la ciudad con millares de flores
animadas y más de 80 zancudos
faltan menos de 100 días para que los
brasileños puedan recuperar su fiesta
más querida
[Música]